really put those on the same level  absolutely racism and sexism  as cultural Appropriations that's  exactly so somebody wears their hair  like you're wearing it you put that on  the same level as as racism absolutely I  put that on the same level as white  supremacy because white supremacy is  intersectional and as a professor at  Arizona State everything that he said  there is complete nonsense except it's  nonsense that has now been wholly  imported into the Democrat Party you can  wear whatever haircut you want you can  make whatever jokes you want you can eat  whatever food you want you can put on  whatever clothes you want to put on  these people don't own you they don't  own your mind they don't know whether  you're doing something to honor it or  make fun of it and guess what you're  also allowed to make fun of things we  used to joke about everything